how can you calculate the square root of
any five digit perfect square without
using a calculator
let's see let's try to find the square
root of 13689
always remember that the square root of
any five digit perfect square will
always be three digits long
let us again do the grouping firstly we
take two digits from the right and then
we look at the remaining ones so here we
have two groups 136 and 89 we can see
that 136 is between 121 and 144 that is
between 11 squared and 12 squared so we
will write the smaller one among the two
which is 11.
here we will write 11.
what will be the units digit it ends
with 9 therefore it will either be 3 or
7. that is why we need to multiply the
lower number with its successor so 11
multiplied by 12 gives us 132.
now we need to compare 136 to this
number now because 136 is greater than
132 we will take the greater of these
two numbers which is seven
we get the answer as one one
for more such interesting tricks do
subscribe to our youtube channel
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below